вітаємо і Ласкаво просимо до програми У
фокусі Європа раді що ви з нами в
останні місяці в Німеччині зросла
кількість особливо небезпечних
пограбувань банків організовані злочинні
угрупування підривають банкомати за
допомогою потужної вибухівки Зазвичай
вони нападають уночі обчищають банкомати
і зникають за лічені хвилини на місці
злочину залишається повний хаос і
руйнування
У деяких випадках ці потужні вибухи не
лише пошкоджують банкомати але й
наражають на серйозну небезпеку місцевих
жителів і перехожих у 2022 році ці
організовані банди викрали мільйони євро
готівкою у банках Німеччини у середньому
щодня відбувається більше одного такого
пограбування що на 27 відсотків більше
ніж минулого року багато із цих
високопрофесійних грабіжників банків
прибувають за меж Німеччини наприклад із
міста еннхеди яке знаходиться на
голландсько-німецькому кордоні
ніякої витонченості лише груба сила
Німеччину охопила хвиля пограбувань
банкоматів
злодії в середньому забирають із собою
десятки тисяч євро
але матеріальні збитки часто набагато
більші
ці злочинці надзвичайно безрозсудні і
безжальні
у нас в землі північний рейнд-вестфалія
було 11 тисяч банкоматів
але за останні шість місяців ця цифра
впала до майже десяти тисяч це все що
доволі багато і вони привабливі мішень
для злодіїв
Минулого року у Німеччині було скоєно
500 пограбувань банкоматів багато банд
приїжджають за кордон зокрема з
Нідерландів
банки Нідерландах краще захищають свої
банкомати тому Нідерланди не Така
приваблива мішень
у Німеччині ж банкоматів багато
і вони наповнені великою кількістю
готівки
у Німеччині Де люблять готівку банкомати
добре заповнені А на автобанах немає
обмежень швидкості ці підозрювані мчать
зі швидкістю 250 кілометрів за годину
щоб утекти від поліції ми супроводжуємо
поліцейських Яно Генріх і берто
брюггенса на службі вони входять до
складу спеціального підрозділу
протягом останніх 15 років німецька та
голландська поліція співпрацюють для
патрулювання кордону та боротьби із
організованою злочинністю в тому числі з
розбійними нападами на банкомати поліція
прагне не розкривати надто багато про
свої тактики
вам потрібні хороші інстинкти
тут на автобані У вас є Лише кілька
секунд аби поглянути на машину і
зазирнути всередину
по рації надходить виклик від
голландської поліції з міста енхеди що
знаходиться по той бік кордону
їхню увагу привернула машина з
німецькими номерними знаками поліцейські
прискорюються щоб перехопити її
Так Ми зупинимо їх через 600 метрів
Куди ви прямуєте додому
поліцейські обшукують автомобіль за
допомогою службового собаки тварини
навчені шукати в тому числі і вибухівку
поліція дійсно щось знаходить але це
лише насіння конопель
ніяких слідів вибухівки чи інструментів
для пограбування банкоматів
у цій грі в кота мишки Поліція часто
приїжджає занадто пізно вони бояться що
колись вибух може стати смертоносним
цей страх поділяє і цей чоловік з
містечка розташованого за сотню
кілометрів від голландського кордону він
не хоче називати свого імені нещодавно
було пограбовано два банкомати неподалік
його сім'я живе над банкоматом між двома
поверхами проходить газопровід який може
вибухнути під час пограбування
нам так страшно що ми звісно дуже погано
спимо у нас все погано Ми весь час
стурбовані вночі ми прокидаємося від
найменшого шуму
місцева і міська Влада знає про
занепокоєння людей
німецькі банківський сектор пообіцяв
федеральному міністру внутрішніх справ
що вони краще захистять свої банкомати
посилять заходи безпеки будуть тримати
менше готівки в банкоматах і
унеможливлять використання вкраденої
готівки
Ми зв'язалися з національною асоціацією
німецьких кооперативних банків щоб
дізнатися більше вони відмовилися давати
інтерв'ю але надіслали нам письмову
заяву
нашим етап протягом багатьох років
запобігати нападам і постійно зменшувати
кількість вибухів банкоматів за
допомогою відповідних превентивних
заходів
однак поки що кінця цьому не видно А
враховуючи зростання кількості
пограбувань банкоматів у Німеччині
наступний напад імовірно може статися
уже за кілька годин
Північна Швеція відома своїми стадами
оленів і незайманої природи оленярство
має давню історію у цій місцевості
допомогло сформувати цей суворий
ландшафт але краєвид може змінитися а
все тому що нещодавно Швеція заявила що
відкрила близько мільйона тонн покладів
рідко земельних мінералів поблизу керуни
свого найпівнічнішого міста ті рід по
земельні метали ключові компоненти в
усьому від акумуляторів електромобілі в
мобільних телефонів до вітрових турбін
проблема полягає в тому що розробка цих
родовищ поставить під загрозою існування
культуру та спадщину оленярів таких як
яуна алас
у квітні крайня північ Швеції досі
вкрита льодом і снігом Вона може
виглядати похмурою але тут вирує життя
[музика]
Північні олені мандрують своїми давніми
маршрутами землями самів останнього
корінного народу Європи
є у на Алла сам він вирушає доглядати за
своїм стадом яке вільно блукає
засніженими просторами
але його спосіб життя в небезпеці роками
ареал проживання оленів скорочується
[оплески]
це наша земля і ми тут господарюємо
нам потрібні великі площі для наших стат
Але з кожним вторгненням сюди ситуація
погіршується
нашорошила вуха кілька оленів заблукали
вони прямують туди де є небезпечне
Дорожнє перехрестя і Залізнична колія
[оплески]
олені йшли У неправильному напрямку але
Ми повернули їх на правильний шлях
усього за кілька кілометрів від них
будують нову шахту прокладають багато
доріг лінії електропередач що також
поставить під загрозу стада
команда державної гірничодобувної
компанії вже заглиблюється вмерзло землю
вони вважають що під землею знаходиться
величезне родовище цінних рідкоземельних
елементів Швеція сподівається отримати
прибуток від цих родовищ і прискорити
перехід на зелену енергетику
Ми не говоримо що це буде легко або
безпроблемно дійсно це може стати
проблемою для саммів але тут ідеться не
лише про оленярів ідеться про Швецію та
європейські Союз усі в світі мають
адаптуватися Ми повинні припинити
викидати так багато СО2 ми всі повинні
йти на певні жертви
[музика]
місто кіруна розташоване на північ від
полярного кола центр гірничодобувної
промисловості Швеції залізну руду тут
видобувають Уже понад 100 років Зараз
шахти планують розширювати щоб
видобувати рідкоземельні метали
пробурюють нові копальні
жеця тут уже давно визначається гірнича
добувної промисловістю коли бурят
новошахту місцеві жителі змушені
звільнити місце
будинки які знаходяться на території
відведені під шахту підлягають знесенню
у тому числі 2500 квартир навіть стару
дерев'яну церкву буде перенесено
бердіта дальберг виросла в хіруні
її колишній будинок зараз стоїть за
будівельним парканом рік тому їй
довелося переїхати
шахтарі надали їй нову квартиру
руда має видобуватися
а звичайні люди не можуть це зупинити
той Хто захоче тут жити коли все
виглядає так як зараз
треба будувати нову керуну
ми впораємося але все одно сумно
втрачати власну історію
[музика]
ще гірше втрачати засоби до існування і
саме це турбує яуну
Про це він часто говорить із Карім
скотаркою із сусіднього села
її стадо також під загрозою і вона
вважає що в цьому Насправді немає
необхідності
ми маємо почати використовувати і
переробляти рідкоземельні елементи які
ми вже маємо лише один відсоток цих
елементів переробляється нам потрібно
покращити переробку перш ніж ми знищимо
ще більше землі та води
донька я Уни також сподівається Одного
дня стати оленяркою саме передають свої
знання і з покоління у покоління
я Уна планує продовжувати протестувати
проти шахти щоб захистити традиційний
спосіб життя самів тут на крайній
півночі Швеції
[музика]
якщо ми перестанемо боротися ми
перестанемо вірити у майбутнє
олені чим стадам потрібно багато місця
для випису
Ми повинні боротися за ці землі щоб
зберегти усе це
[музика]
станда підуть високо в гори і є у на
аллас піде з ними
[музика]
у всьому світі більшість професійних
пожежників чоловіки існує хибна думка що
жінки не можуть впоратися із фізичними
вимогами цієї роботи Іспанія не виняток
але незабаром це може змінитися у
Каталонії на північному сході країни
вирішили що 40% новобранців повинні
складати жінки ця фотографія зі змішаних
навчань які сьогодні радше виняток
незабаром може стати нормою але нове
ініціатива безумовно викликали дискусії
Дехто каже що каталонський уряд зайшов
Надто далеко в прагнені до рівності інші
кажуть що для Іспанії Настав час зробити
Крок уперед і подолати цей гендерний
розрив
пожежна служба північно-східного
іспанського міста гранульєрс проводить
навчання для Марії каселас Це звичайний
робочий день вона одна з небагатьох
жінок пожежниць у Каталонії незабаром їх
стане більше завдяки новій гендерній
квоті
до дівчини я не могла уявити що стану
пожежницею жінки це не займалися Але я
думаю що коли люди побачать жінок які
виконують цю роботу це за охотить інших
жінок теж спробувати
[музика]
однак поки жінки залишаються винятком у
каталонській пожежній охороні вони
складають менше трьох відсотків
особового складу
сьогодні Марія тренується із жінками
пожежницями з регіону на цих навчаннях
Вони мають врятувати пораненого водія
використовуючи важке обладнання це
надзвичайно крупітка робота яка вимагає
великої майстерності
[музика]
Мені дуже подобається
коли починає щось о сьомій ранку ніколи
не знаєш що на тебе чекає
і ти працюєш у команді тож ніколи не
залишаєшся сам
регіональний уряд Каталонії запровадив
квоту для збільшення кількості жінок у
пожежній охороні 40% нових вакансій
призначені для жінок
Марія муніс задоволена новою квотою Вона
одна з небагатьох жінок на високих
посадах у департаменті і очолює команду
чоловіків у командному центрі
командна робота - це ключ до цієї справи
Чим більш різноманітними ми будемо тим
ефективніше будемо справлятися з
надзвичайними ситуаціями це науково
доведено
кожен виклик відрізняється від інших
тому ми виграємо від того що у нас
будуть люди з різними талантами сила
урізноманітності
але квота викликали дебати у відділенні
багато пожежників чоловіків кажуть що
вступні вимоги для чоловіків і жінок
Мають бути однаковими
мовляв саме це і називається рівністю
еухеніо замбранос профспілки
держслужбовців вважає що квота перевищує
свою мету
суспільство повинно підходити до цього
більш розумно шукати талановитих людей
незалежно від того чоловіки сечі жінки
нам потрібно змінити спосіб мислення
Мені потрібно хороший лікар і не важливо
Чи це чоловік чи жінка мені потрібні
хороші пожежники не важливо чоловіки чи
жінки наші урядовці повинні зосередитися
на здібностях і навичках ось що потрібно
нашому суспільству
це гаряча тема серед самих пожежників
Марія не хоче коментувати на відміну від
її колег чоловіків
тепер жінки знищені балими можуть пройти
вступний тест просто тому що для них
зарезервовані місця
а чоловік з вищим балом може не пройти
керівництво Департаменту кажуть що це не
проблема
квота - це певний сигнал але головне
навички та здібності жінка кандидатка
отримує роботу тільки у тому випадку
якщо вона настільки кваліфікована як і
чоловік
на сьогоднішній зустрічі голова
каталонської пожежної служби має хороші
новини Минулого року лише один з дев'яти
кандидатів був жінкою цього року кожен
четвертий
У нас є проблема і нам потрібно її
вирішити
Ми не можемо чекати поки вільний ринок
вирішить її
через 10-15 років у нас все одно майже
не буде жінок у пожежної охорони
тому ми намагаємося прискорити цей
процес
за наші права гасло цього тренінгу
жінки пожежники Каталонії пишаються
своїми досягненнями
немає значення чоловікими чи жінки Ми
біжимо на зустріч вогню коли інші
тікають від нього
Марія каже що робота пожежника вимагає
відваги та пристрасті і вона рада що
незабаром більше жінок будуть працювати
пліч-о-пліч із нею
А тепер до іншої традиційно чоловічої
сфери футбольний клуб ньюкасла Юнайтед
довгий час борсався на дні англійської
прем'єр-ліги але у 2021 році поглинання
за сприяння Саудівської Аравії за одну
ніч зробило Нью касу найбагатшим
футбольним клубом у світі та деякі давні
вболівальники такі як деніелл прегон не
святкують тепернюкало фінансується
державним інвестиційним фондом
Саудівської Аравії і Деніел підозрює що
у саудовців можуть бути інші мотиви
окрім чистої пристрасті до спорту
Ньюкасл повернувся вболівальники
англійського футбольного клубу знову
відчувають гордість за свою команду
протягом багатьох років Ньюкасл Юнайтед
був скрудному становищі але все
змінилося після того як клуб придбав
саудівський консорціум і витрати близько
300 мільйонів євро на підписання
контрактів і стоп талантами
Я думаю що це відчуття на яке Ми так
довго чекали на стало Це просто
неймовірне відчуття ми просто хочемо
побачити тут якийсь Трофей це все що нас
зараз турбує
проте не всі радіють до них належать і
Деніелс прегон протягом 30 років він був
постійним відвідувачем стадіону тепер
він просто приходить швидко поглянути і
йде геть на знак протесту
я не можу більше сидіти там на території
це розчаровує це сумно але я відчуваю що
не можу там бути Я відчуваю дискомфорт
сотні інших вболівальників відчувають те
саме зараз Деніел дивиться матчі у
місцевому пабі по суті Саудівська
держава тепер володіє контрольним
пакетом акцій його клубу
Але я думаю що коли інша країна держава
стає власником вашого клубу Ви повинні
бути свідомими Ви маєте усвідомлювати як
вони поводяться І як це впливає на вас І
що це означає для вашого міста
мотиви Саудівської Аравії зрештою
полягають не лише в грі пустельна Країна
має величезні нафтові багатства але вона
наражається на міжнародну критику через
проблеми з дотриманням прав людини
прем'єр-міністра Саудівської Аравії
спадкоємний принц Мухаммед Бім Салман
має репутацію безжального
кажуть є докази що він замовив вбивство
джамаля хашоджі критика режиму
крон принца заперечує ці звинувачення
але вони шкодять його іміджу
це лише одна із причин чому Саудівській
суверенний фонд придбав популярний
футбольний клуб Ньюкасл фонд державних
інвестицій має одномісію забезпечити
процвітання Саудівської Аравії запаси
нафти Колись вичерпаються він салмана
особисто керує фондом
журналіст Аарон стоукс спостерігає за
тим як нові саудівські власники
відшліфовують свій імідж
вони вклали гроші в ігрову команду за
лаштунками Я маю на увазі що навіть
знаєте зміну назви бару на ширес була
дуже великою справою люди потягнулися до
кишені справді допомогли ви знаєте
фан-банк пожертвував 150 тисяч фунтів
Стерлінг кілька місяців тому фан-зона
також буде побудована поруч зі стадіоном
цей крок переконав багатьох скептиків я
безумовно думаю що вони намагатимуться
зробити те саме зі школами та житловими
будинками в подальшому я думаю що якщо
вони повернуться сюди через 15 років ця
територія Мені здається буде повністю
відремонтована і відроджена
Ньюкасл ледальне місце місто відчайдушно
потребує інвестицій особливо у житловий
будівництво і тут є багато землі для
будівництва у привабливих районах але
отримати її не так просто для чого не
обов'язково купувати футбольний клуб є
відповідні канали через які ми можемо
пройти але звісно ці канали бюрократичні
це займає багато часу
набагато простіше якщо ви можете сказати
гей Приходьте на гру в суботу це чудовий
спосіб побудови взаємин це чудовий
спосіб налагодити діалог та мати вплив
переваги які дає володіння футбольним
клубом також очевиднів Манчестері Ман
Сіті належить об'єднаним арабським
еміратам вони викупили у міста землю
центральній частині і побудували 1600
квартир Річард Голдінг та його колеги
уважно вивчили цю угоду те що вони
знайшли шокувало їх
місто віддало землю дуже дешево усе це
всього за 5 мільйонів фунтів стерлінгів
місто каже що не могло виторгувати
кращої ціни власники клубу тепер
матимуть прибуток на довгі роки за
нашими оцінками Вони отримують близько
10 мільйонів фунтів стерлінгів орендної
плати на рік і це великий Грошовий потік
багато інвесторів вхопилися б за таку
можливість
тож володіння футбольним клубом може
відчинити двері як вдома так і за
кордоном якщо клуб виграє Чемпіонат
Саудівська Аравія прагне отримати
фінансову чи економічну віддачу від
інвестицій Або можливо політичну вигоду
Деніел прегон розчарований у своєму
місті як він це бачить
Ньюкасл піддався саудівському
спортивному промиванню
але він не готовий розділяти цю позицію
брейк данс - це сила творчість і ритм це
як акробатичний танець народився у
1970-х роках на вулицях бронса в
нью-йорку
тоді ніхто і гадки не мав що колись ці
рухи стануть олімпійською дисципліною
однак тепер брейк-данс дебютує на літніх
Олімпійських іграх у Парижі у 2024 році
Це буде перший танцювальний вид спорту
на Олімпійських іграх
і це безумовно тема що варто з
нетерпінням чекати Дякуємо за перегляд і
Бережіть себе до побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]